HALF THE COUNTRY HE WAS ELECTED
TO LEAD.
JOINING ME NOW IS STEVEN MILLER
FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FOUNDER OF
AMERICA FIRST LEGAL, CURT SENIOR
COLUMNIST OF TownHall.com AND
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK WE'LL BE
BACK, AND CHARLIE KIRK, FOUNDER
OF TURNING POINT USA AND AUTHOR
OF THE GREAT BOOK THE COLLEGE
SCAM.
ALL RIGHT, STEVEN, I WANT TO
COME TO YOU FIRST AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS ALL JOINING
ME.
JOE BIDEN IS BASICALLY SAYING
THAT IT'S ACCEPTABLE TO TARGET
REPUBLICANS WITH THE FULL FORCE
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT EVEN
USING THE FBI.
>> WELL, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HE'S SAYING.
LET'S NOT FORGET THIS IS THE
PARTY THAT LOCKED PEOPLE IN
THEIR HOMES IN BLUE STATES AND
BLUE CITIES, TOOK AWAY PEOPLE'S
MOST ESSENTIAL FREEDOMS.
AT THIS VERY MOMENT IN TIME
THEY'RE MASKING CHILDREN IN
DEMOCRAT CITIES LIKE
PHILADELPHIA DESURPRISING THEM
OF AN EDUCATION, MURIEL BOOZER
IS DESURPRISING BLACK STUDENTS
EVEN THE RIGHT TO ATTEND SCHOOL
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T RECEIVED A
VACCINATION.
AND OF COURSE THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS LAUNCHED
A POLITICAL RAID OF HIS CHIEF
POLITICAL OPPONENT'S HOME TO
SEIZE AND STEAL HIS PROPERTY AND
HIS DOCUMENTS.
SO WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS A
CLASSIC TECHNIQUE OF TIE RANTS
AND AUTHOR TARNS WHERE THEY USE
THE METHODS OF DICTATORSHIP
WHILE ACCUSING THEIR OPPONENTS
OF BEING FASCIST?
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
AUTHORITARIAN AND OPPRESSIVE.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS VIOLATING
OUR LAWS INCLUDING VIOLATING OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS WITH IMPUNITY
AND HELPING MURDEROUS CRIMINAL
CARTELS VIOLATE OUR SOVEREIGNTY
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, IT'S RICH TO
CALL REPUBLICANS FASCIST.
CHARLIE I LOOK AT THIS AND, YOU
TALK ABOUT THE MAGA MOVEMENT AND
I KNOW PEOPLE WELL WHO SUPPORT
DONALD TRUMP, I THINK THE WHOLE
PANEL DOES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT BELIEVE IN
GOD, COUNTRY, FAITH, HARD WORK,
PATRIOTISM.
THEY SALUTE THE FLAG AND STAND
UP FOR THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
THESE ARE TRADITIONAL AMERICANS
AND THEY'RE CALLING THEM
FASCISTS?
>> AND THEIR LANGUAGE IS PRECISE
FOR A REASON.
I MEAN WHAT -- IF YOU ACTUALLY
ENCOUNTERED A FASCIST THEN WHAT
WOULDN'T YOU DO AGAINST THAT
PERSON.
THEY'RE CALLING HALF THE COUNTRY
FASCIST THEN IT JUSTIFIES A
PATRIOT ACT 2.0 RESPONSE TO SPY,
INFILTRATE MONITOR SUBVERT
POLITICAL GROUPS THEY DON'T
LIKE.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
THEIR REGIME IS FALLING APART.
THEIR POLICIES ARE UNPOPULAR.
PEOPLE ARE REALIZING HOW
TRANSPARENTLY AWFUL THEY ARE
ABOUT GOVERNING.
THE ONLY THING THEY HAVE LEFT IS
THE POWER OF THE FEW AGAINST THE
MANY.
THE FBI, THE DOJ, FACEBOOK,
GOOGLE, AND THE WAY THEY'RE ABLE
DO THAT IS CALL HALF THE COUNTRY
FASCIST.
STEPHEN SAID IT PERFECTLY.
THEY'RE THE FASCISTS.
IF THEY WANT TO USE EVERY
COMPARISON FROM THE 1930s, FINE,
WHICH ARE THE ONES USING THE FBI
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES LOCKING
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES AND DOING
FAVORS FOR THEIR POLITICAL
DONORS?
FASCISM IS STATE CONTROL OF
BUSINESS AND BOY DOES IT LOOK
LIKE JOE BIDEN IS USING
GOVERNMENT FOR HIS CRONIES AND
HIS BUSINESS PURPOSES AGAINST
THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: CHARLIE YOU MAKE A
POINT BECAUSE IF YOU HAD
SOMETHING TO RUN ON, IF YOU HAD
A RECORD TO RUN ON YOU WOULD RUN
ON IT.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT INFLATION,
GAS, BORDER, CRIME, AFGHANISTAN,
JOE BIDEN HAS NOTHING TO RUN ON
SO WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE ATTACKS REPUBLICANS WITH, YOU
KNOW, OUTRAGES TERMS LIKE THIS.
BUT CURT I WANT TO COME TO YOU,
THE DOJ CHAIR JAMIE HARRISON WAS
ASKED ABOUT THE BIDEN SEMI
FASCIST COMMENT AND HOW IT
SQUARES WITH HIS CALLS FOR
UNITY.
WATCH.
>> THE ONE THING PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN HAS BEEN IS ALWAYS BEEN
CONSISTENT AND HE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN SOMEBODY WHO DOES WHAT MY
GRANDFATHER USED TO DO WHICH IS
SPEAK IT PLAIN, SAY IT PLAIN TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND WHAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW IS A
FULL FRONTAL ATTACK BY THESE
EXTREME MAGA REPUBLICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: HE'S CONSISTENT, CURT.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> HE'S CONSISTENT ALL RIGHT,
SEAN.
HE'S BEEN A CONSISTENT MORE ON
FOR 50 YEARS IN WASHINGTON AND
NOW HE'S A SENILE ONE AS WELL.
I DON'T NEED TO BE LECTURED ON
PATRIOTISM BY SOME GUY WHO GOT
OUT OF MILITARY SERVICE WITH A
CASE OF ASTHMA THAT DISAPPEARED
AS SOON AS THE DRAFT HIT.
I DEPLOYED FOR MY COUNTRY TWO
TIMES.
I DON'T NEED TO BE QUESTIONED BY
THIS HACK OR ANY OF HIS HACK
FRIENDS LIKE THIS CLOWN.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY DESTRUCTIVE.
THIS IS INCREDIBLY
DESTABILIZING.
LOOK, I SERVED IN PLACES WHERE
THE NORMS FELLOW WAY, WHERE THE
SYSTEM FELL APART, WHERE IT
TURNED INTO CONFLICT BECAUSE ONE
GROUP DECIDES IT WANT POWER AND
IT DIDN'T CARE WHAT IT HAD TO DO
TO GET IT.
THAT'S WHAT THESE GUYS ARE
DOING.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
AND IT'S ALSO -- AND IT'S MORE
THAN DANGEROUS.
IT'S SQUANDERING THE INHERITANCE
THAT WE RECEIVED FROM THE
AMERICANS THAT CAME BEFORE WHO
BUILT THIS COUNTRY INTO THE
FREEST, MOST PROSPEROUS MOST
POWERFUL COUNTRY THAT EVER
EXISTED.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
YOU KNOW, IF HE WASN'T SO
MANIFESTLY SENILE I WOULD EXPECT
HIM TO BE ASHAMED OF HIMSELF BUT
HE CAN'T DO THAT.
THERE'S NO EXCUSE FOR HIS
MINIONS, THOUGH.
THEY SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
IT'S OBNOXIOUS.
>> Sean: YOU'RE RIGHT BECAUSE
WHEN YOU START TO BREAK THESE
NORMS AND START TO DO THINGS
WE'VE NEVER DONE IN OUR PAST,
IT'S REALLY HARD TO, YOU KNOW,
PUT THINGS BACK TOGETHER.
BECAUSE WHAT, NOW YOU SAY
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE THIS TO
REPUBLICANS, DO REPUBLICANS GO
BACK TO THE NORM OR DO
REPUBLICANS ACTUALLY DO THIS
BACK TO DEMOCRATS?
I MEAN, THINGS START TO DEVOLVE.
BUT, STEPHEN, THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME DEMOCRATS HAVE TALKED
LIKE THIS.
GO BACK TO BARACK OBAMA WHEN HE
SAID REPUBLICANS CLING TO THEIR
BIBLES AND THEIR GUNS OR HILLARY
CLINTON CALLED REPUBLICANS OR
TRUMP SUPPORTERS A BASKET OF
DEPLORABLES.
THIS DEMEANING DEROGATORY
LANGUAGE TRYING OUTER EYES
REPUBLICANS.
>> YES, I WANT TO PICK UP TO
SOMETHING TO THAT POINT THAT
CHARLIE SAID WHICH IS THAT
YOU'RE SETTING THE STAGE WITH
THIS RHETORIC TO USE THE AWESOME
POWER OF THE STATE TO PERSECUTE
POLITICAL DECENTERS.
TO PERSECUTE TRADITIONAL
AMERICANS, FAITHFUL AMERICANS,
CONSERVATIVE AMERICANS,
BIBLE-BELIEVING AMERICANS.
JUST LIKE YOU SAW GARLAND WITH N
ICE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OBJECTING TO PARENTS AGAINST
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE THEM USING
THE POWERS OF THE SECURITY
INSTITUTE SUR VEIL AMERICANS, TO
SENSOR AMERICANS, TO SILENCE
AMERICANS IN FULL COLLUSION WITH
BIG TECH.
AND SO YOU ARE GOING TO SEE, IF
WE DON'T THROW THE RADICAL LEFT
OUT OF POWER, YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE OUR CIVIL LIBERTIES SHIFT
AWAY IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD TERRIFY ALL
AMERICANS.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE
REPUBLICAN.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE DEMOCRAT.
WHEN BIDEN TALKS THIS WAY ABOUT
PEOPLE HE DISAGREES WITH, HE IS
SAYING, ANY TACTIC, ANY MEASURE,
ANYTHING WOULD BE JUSTIFIED
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE EVIL.
THAT IS TRULY FRIGHTENING.
>> Sean: YOU'RE RIGHT STEPHEN WE
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WE
DISAGREE WITH, ADAMANTLY
DISAGREE WITH BECAUSE THAT'S THE
WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS.
>> CHARLIE WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
THE EFFECTS OF WHAT BIDEN SAID.
TODAY RNC CHAIR WOMAN 'RONA
McDANIELS TWEETED OUT THIS
PICTURE WRITING THE SEMI GOP
OFFICE WAS VANDALIZED OVERNIGHT.
THE CRIMINALS ECHOED BIDEN'S
FASCIST SLANDER.
THE GOP WILL NOT BE INTIMIDATED.
CHARLIE ARE YOU EXPECTING TO SEE
MORE OF THIS WITH BIDEN ACE
RHETORIC AND DEMOCRATS ACTING ON
THAT RHETORIC.
>> UNFORTUNATELY YES AND WE SEE
THIS ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES ALL THE
TIME, WHEN I VISIT COLLEGE
CAMPUSES WE SEE THE INCREASE OF
VIOLENCE AND HATRED AND YOU LOOK
AT IT AS ALMOST THE WUHAN LAB
EQUIVALENT WHERE THIS SORT OF
BEHAVIOR IS INCUBATED.
WHERE DO YOU THINK THAT IDEA OF
FASCISM AND THE IDEA OF FIGHTING
FASCISM COMES FROM?
UC BERKELEY AND STANFORD AND
YALE WHERE IT BECOMES COOL AND
GERM NATES THE REST OF SOCIETY.
SO UNFORTUNATELY I DO EXPECT THE
KIND OF VIOLENCE TO CONTINUE.
WE HAVE TO REMAIN PEACEFUL ON
OUR SIDE.
BUT I DO THINK IF THEY'RE GOING
TO ESCALATE THE LANGUAGE THEN
GAME ON.
LIKE OKAY.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO CALL US A
BUNCH OF FASCISTS, WE'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE THAT ANYMORE,
YOU'RE THE FASCIST JOE BIDEN AND
OTHER WORDS AS WELL.
WE'RE NOT GOING BACK TO I WOULD
LIKE TO GO BACK TO 2014.
THAT'S OVER AND DONE.
THEY'RE CALLING YOU THE WORST
THING THAT CAN BE CALLED IN
DECENT POLITICAL CONVERSATION.
AND WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
WE NEED TO FIND A COMMON GROUND.
NO, WE HAVE TO WIN.
WE HAVE TO DISPLACE THESE PEOPLE
FROM POWER RIGHT NOW.
PAY ATTENTION.
THIS IS THE RUBICON THAT'S BEEN
CROSSED WHEN THEY CALL HALF THE
COUNTRY FASCIST.
>> Sean: GOVERNMENT, SOCIETY,
POLITICS ALL DEINVOLVES.
CURT, 20 SECONDS, FINAL WORD TO
YOU.
>> LOOK, SEAN, THIS ISN'T
HAPPENING BECAUSE THEY'RE
WINNING.
THIS IS HAPPENING BECAUSE
THEY'RE LOSING AND THEY'RE
DESPERATE.
LOOK AT THE APPROVAL POLLS.
BIDEN IS POLLING RIGHT UP THERE
WITH MONKEYPOX.
OKAY?
THESE GUYS, YOU KNOW, THESE GUYS
LOST IN VIRGINIA, THEY'RE LOSING
AT THE SCHOOL BOARDS.
HISPANIC AMERICANS ARE FLOCKING
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BECAUSE
IT'S THE PARTY OF FAITH, FAMILY
AND THE FLAG, JUST LIKE HISPANIC
AMERICANS LOVE.
THEY ARE DESPERATE.
AND THE PROBLEM IS, WHEN
SOMEBODY'S DESPERATE, HE DOES
STUPID THINGS.
AND, OF COURSE, YOU MULTIPLY
THAT BY JOE BIDEN, WHO'S MADE A
CAREER OF DOING STUPID THINGS,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A BUMPY
RIDE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU'RE RIGHT,
AMER